okay so i'm going to move a little
and i push through do you see i haven't
grabbed yet
what is going to follow the same rules
like they're aligned
to the body his body
push through elbows
not wrist elbow that's not gonna work
[Music]
so when you leave kihon and it's
more dynamic and he's doing whatever he
wants and maybe you have weapons on
and you're trying to get to him and he's
trying to get to them or you're trying
to keep them and it's all
he's changing levels and he's changing
ranges
striking goes to grappling takedown he's
trying
all these things you you can't get
hands it does does not work
okay does not work you ha you cannot
go from hands to body that's what does
not work
that your keyhole at first glance makes
you think you're doing that
but it doesn't work and that's why when
we go to live training environments
you have like zero percent success rate
okay
or even in a live network environment
you don't you don't find your locks
because
you're trying to control their body by
controlling their
arms it's the other way control the body
and then you find arms okay so
the first body control is the same drill
from yesterday
it's in here
[Music]
i'm not controlling his arm
it's go it's going right into his body
right into his body
not on his arm his body
okay so i pushed his body and he
braced you see look that brace
is what allows me to get his elbow
he flew and the technique but
i go for his body braces that's how he
did his elbow
okay so i have to follow the rule
so body there's no more body in there
because you break
well you want to go here do you see
some people have a strong grip i can't i
can't go there
let's say you do get it what's
controlling him now
his elbow is bendable you see
so you always go from body
to shoulder to elbow to wrist
because you want to stay as close to the
body as possible
wrist is last stitch fingers last stitch
so let's roll when i trade the contact
point
okay come in do you see
now i have this body oh then i can find
these
so i was in the body oh
i'm still in the body come in can't come
in
come in hand coming you see oh you're
thinking oh you got me here no
no you're dumb okay you don't
because i don't have his body
and he's just going to push through
doesn't work like that
so even when i'm doing nico push through
you see it's not it's not a wrist
technique
so the same thing in his body you can
cover
you can check you can be ready to catch
it but don't lose
this is not controlling you so here
that's controlling it then find it
[Music]
so don't start walking like this
too much pressure for a motel okay hold
up
[Music]
okay so just like a mote on this
step here his shoulder goes down
and i'm i'm on the inside of his arm not
on
the top i'm on the inside that's why i
can go around this thing like this
okay
so that this step here on board
same exact thing it's not going this way
i'm not bringing him around he does go
around but i'm not bringing him around
i'm not going like this
i'm aiming his shoulder down
his shoulder goes down
shoulder down
down hand is still up
then
oh
shoulder down then hand
don't bring them around bring them down
and you go around
go